m
ce mercredi 13 avril au parc des
expositions de la nordev s'est déroulée
la finale académique du concours c'est
génial 24 collèges de l'île étaient
présents pour exposer au jury leurs
projets scientifiques innovant élaboré
au cours de l'année scolaire le le
concours section des collèges et des
écoles qui doivent présenter à un
concours scientifique ou technologique
donc tout au long de l'année ça commence
à partir du mois de septembre pour une
présentation donc au mois d'avril
donc c'est un concours qui est qu'elle
est fait dans toutes les académies de
france donc trop tard académie dans
chaque académie donc ce le lauréat il
est qualifié pour la finale à paris qui
va avoir lieu c'est nier le 21 mai
chaque projet est vu par par deux jurys
différents des jurys composés donc de
professeur d'université de professeurs
de lycées des inspecteurs et de
professeurs aussi du premier degré un
concours qui permet aux jeunes de
présenter un projet didactique et
innovants dans les domaines scientifique
et technique
c'est un concours qui permet il n'y a
pas que ce concours la multi permet de
nous développer l'appétence et le goût
des élèves pour les sciences
l'enseignement des sciences n'est pas tu
revaloriser le développer sur les
véhicules
la curiosité des élèves ici par une
démarche de pédagogie de projet un
groupe d'élèves assiste évidemment d'un
ou plusieurs enseignants participent à
un vrai travail de recherche
d'investigation les collèges étant une
compétence de la collectivité
départementale tout naturellement
l'institution était représentée au sein
du jury tous les marmailles qui
participe là aujourd'hui ils ont trouvé
un bonheur à venir ici ils sont épanouis
et en ce sens a rejoint pleinement ce
que fait le conseil départemental dans
sa mission éducation
il vise pleinement l'éducation de
l'enfant et c'est pour ça que mais on se
retrouve en tout pas aujourd'hui réunis
tous ensemble pour évaluer finalement ce
que font les uns les autres dans les
établissements tout au long de la
journée les membres du jury ont fait le
tour des stands pour noter des projets
scientifiques des élèves sur différents
critères tels que l'originalité la
maîtrise du sujet ou encore la qualité
de la présentation aujourd'hui on va
présenter notre jardin vertical 3d tron
tiennent avec un panneau solaire
en fait c'est tout d'abord un projet
pour la ville du futur parce que nous on
imaginer vue du futur autonome en
énergie plutôt deux
voilà quand même surtout quand les gens
en appartement il est leur propre
potager
lorsque nous avons mis en place pour ce
combo pour ce concours c'est que nous
avons travaillé sur la thématique ne
sont pas c'était la terre formation de
masse
comment
habiter masmes comment vivre sur mars
est donc pas pour cela on avait
travaillé plusieurs problématiques
peut-être que par an pour moi n'essaient
pas de vie sur mars pourquoi surtout
inquiète a dit et pas sur mars donc on a
donc fait cette différence pour
travailler pas sûr on ne sait pas dire
non en fait on a utilisé plus pour la
méthanisation
donc comme on parle ici d'un la famille
d'ali ziat domestique va pouvoir
récupérer les déchets ménagers fallait
déchets cuisiner tout et on fait du gaz
c'est une voiture qui a agacé quand on
tape au filet donc mon monteur il est là
après délibération du jury c'est le
collège de plateau caillou avec son
jardin vertical 3d qui remporte cette
finale académique
les élèves se rendront à paris le 21 mai
pour la finale nationale